hey everybody welcome back to Planet zoo
this is going to be my last video of the
beta because the beta is going to end in
a few hours from now but by the time
this goes live it's definitely long over
so the next Planet 2 videos you'll see
on my channel are going to be in a few
weeks when the full game goes live which
is actually kind of a good thing because
I'm gonna need those few weeks did not
play this game anymore because it has
kind of taken over my life even my
parents sent me very concerned text
about my upload rate which is pretty
unusually high anyway you probably don't
want to hear me talk about that instead
I should probably talk about the habitat
that I'm building in this video which is
going to be for the Formosan black bears
now I know that I was already building a
habitat for bears in the last episode I
know it's it's not going to be great
youtuber thumbnail clickbait there's no
amazing megaphone and like lions or
Tigers no it's just going to be Formosan
black bears no offense to the black
bears but I have to say they were the
only thing that I could actually afford
because as you can see my credits aren't
that high and this game has really kind
of made me lose faith in humanity
because people put animals on the trade
center for ridiculous price tags I've
seen P files for 10000 conservation
credits like Y so yeah I couldn't really
afford anything but these black bears I
decided to get them when I could because
I do like them they're pretty cute and
also and this is maybe more important in
my case I like the fact that they're
from Taiwan and this gave me some ideas
for theming that I haven't really tried
before and you're probably already
getting an idea of what I'm going for
here if you have a decent knowledge of
Chinese architecture and things like
that at the moment I'm working on a moon
bridge which is originally a bridge
designed from China which was supposed
to be built like this
so that boats could pass underneath it
but it also has some added advantages of
having no slope necessary to go toward
the bridge because it is quite steep on
the sides so you don't need a lot of
space for it and also let's be honest
they look pretty cool now it may not be
that obvious that I'm going for a
Chinese theme for this habitat but
well Taiwan has a very unique mixed
architectural history there are
indigenous traditions and it's been
ruled as a colony by the Dutch Spanish
Chinese and Japanese and there are all
kinds of leftovers of this not to
mention that it exists in kind of an
iffy political state at the moment but
regardless of all this it there really
is a lot that you can see in Taiwan as
far as I'm aware I've actually never
been there myself even though I would
like to go there but I decided to go for
Chinese architecture because it's really
the most common and you find a lot of
Chinese architecture there and it's
something that I wanted to try in
general and given the fact that Formosan
black bears are from Taiwan it's pretty
relevant I think speaking of which I was
wondering what Formosan meant actually
exactly and turns out that it does refer
to the indigenous people of Taiwan and
their language and culture which makes
sense actually my first encounter with
this term was for Mosin Aboriginal
cultural village which is a theme park
in Taiwan and given my theme park
background I used to be interested in
that because it's quite an interesting
park that has a bakoma slc with really
cool theming around it but yeah I'm
going way off topic here that is in any
case what the Bears are from and what I
was inspired by for this habitat now if
you've been following me on Twitter
which by the way I have Twitter and if
you don't follow me yet you can find me
in a link in the description or just
find me yourself my name is silver 'it's
basically the exact same as on all
platforms ever but yeah I've been
posting a bunch about my philosophy
behind habitats and what I think they
should be like and personally what
inspired me for this habitats and what
I'll probably try to stick to for all of
my future habitats as well is to try and
provide a combination of the nature and
culture of whatever country or region
the animals are from but I do want to be
very strictly separating the human and
the natural elements of this so I want
to make sure that I try to make the
nature as
antek as possible for the animal
habitants but at the same time try to
have authentic culture for human
visitors and this is an idea that
generally was inspired by a visit to
Patti dizer a lot of people have been
asking me about whether I've actually
been to that park which yes I have you
can stop asking me that
and while I think the theming is really
beautiful it's a zoo with a lot of
themed areas representing different
parts of the world and supposedly all of
the buildings have even been designed
with help from architects and materials
from all these different places to be as
authentic as possible and this is all
really beautiful but at the same time I
think there's a sort of mismatch of sort
of dissonance between all of this
beautiful scenery and the animals on the
other hand for one for one example
there's a there's a tiger exhibit which
is in a South East Asian style temple
building which is really cool it's a
really beautiful building but at the
same time they just put the tigers in
the middle of this building and it
doesn't really provide the natural
surroundings like trees and enrichments
that these Tigers need I think as at
least as far as I'm aware it's really
kind of shoehorning these animals into
structures that are made by and for
humans which to me is kind of
problematic so I'd like to take that
idea of representing this these cultures
from all over the world and adding this
animal and even a foliage element to it
but at the same time trying to separate
them a bit more and establish these
boundaries between nature and human a
bit better and for this habitat I think
you can already kind of see that in a
sense that I will be building a lot of
Chinese inspired structures like the
bridge and like the like the pavilion
which I'm currently working on which
I'll get to in a minute but at the same
time I want to restrict these to the
guest areas only which I think makes
more sense even from a cultural
standpoint because these pavilions for
instance the one that I'm working on
right now is traditionally used in
Chinese gardens as a real viewing spots
to be inside
to view the garden from to provide a
center point for gardens for humans and
while I think the idea to perhaps turn
it into a shelter for animals is
tempting I think that just that's kind
of Kitsch and definitely doesn't matter
to the animal welfare at all because
animals can't really you know benefits
in any way from being in a very flashy
beautiful structure that's very detailed
and made to be nice to humans so on the
topic of this pavilion actually to bring
it back a little bit this is my first
try to kill myself playing this game
because god this was really difficult
for some reason I had the idea to build
a Chinese pavilion in the game and
obviously since there is no Chinese
theme at least not in the beta and it
hasn't been confirmed for the full game
either
although I do secretly hope and kind of
think there will be one given the fact
that there is Asian sounding music in
the soundtrack of the game but anyway I
wanted to build one of these pavilions
myself and this turned out to be quite a
difficult quest for one because the
pieces are very limited so I ended up
using some lines limestone corner pieces
to build these curved dividers for the
roof I ended up building six of these
because I wanted to make this a hexagon
shaped Chinese pavilion there are many
different shapes and sizes of these
sorts of pavilions but personally I
really like the hexagon shaped ones with
the curved roofs for me that feels like
the right balance and then between these
there will be in real life tiled roofs
that curve to the sides of these and
also curved inwards themselves a little
bit to create these really cool core
curved structures and this was really
difficult to recreate in game because we
also don't have any separate tile roof
pieces so the piece that I ended up
using for this tiled roof is actually
the full-stop from the alphabets setting
or the alphabet sets I suppose of
scenery pieces which in hindsight I have
to spoil was a terrible idea
the
while I was building this whole
structure I didn't really test this but
as soon as I finished the structure and
I zoomed out a bit I realized that the
render distance of these pieces is
abysmal and as soon as you zoomed out a
bit the whole structure would completely
disappear which I'll get to fixing in a
minute but yeah that made using these
pieces kind of impractical so as good as
I think it looks because it does look
surprisingly convincing I think for a
tile roof with these sort of concrete
dividing decoration elements I think it
looks quite decent but once you zoom out
the whole thing disappears so eventually
I ended up having to sink some larger
pieces in there which disappear less
quickly just to make sort of an LOD for
this whole pavilion which is something
that I'll do in a minute once I'm done
with these pillars and the fence around
people go in as well now I always get a
lot of comments from people why I'm not
just using a 3d modelling program to do
some stuff that I do and for this one I
was definitely feeling like that's
because realistically what I ended up
doing is making a lower detail version
of this pavilion right underneath the
existing one just to make sure that it
doesn't completely disappear when you
zoom out which is something that if
you're working on game design and you're
making 3d models you have to provide
these Elodie's to them so yeah maybe I
did go into a 3d model development
direction with this one aside from that
though I do feel like this was
surprisingly easy a lot of it just comes
down to the rotational symmetry and
making a good cutouts of the shape of
the building that you want before you
build anything else because the way that
it works is just you make one side and
then you copy it over to the other side
and start rotating it to create the
whole structure so when they say in this
case since I was building a hexagon
shaped pavilion I had to make sure to
build 1/6 of the pavilion just finish
that and copy it over to the other side
and then rotate it
fill in the other five parts of the
pavilion unfortunately it was a little
bit off grid so fitting these pieces
together without leaving any gaps
between them was a bit difficult but in
the end I think it connects quite
seamlessly and whatever the case I'm
really happy with how this turned out it
definitely turned out a bit better than
I was expecting and I say that with full
experience of trying to make Asian roofs
in a planet game since I tried to do the
same for fantasy belly in planet coaster
which I also think turned out a little
bit less nice than this building and I
didn't even dare at the time to try and
build a Chinese pavilion like this with
six sides so definitely happy that I
tried this and then it worked out as
well as it did if not just for the one
little issue that it disappears a bit
too quickly when you zoom out but I
think the lower detail elements that I
added underneath these roof tiles do
make up for that and once you zoom out
you just basically see a lower detail
version of this pavilion
now around this one side of it will be
the habitats and the other side which is
here will be a garden and there aren't
gonna be any exhibits or buildings in
this space I'm really just trying to
provide this pavilion with a Chinese
style garden context just because I
think that's what realistically these
kinds of pavilions should fit into which
is also I suppose inspired a bit by pi d
dizer I have to admit as much as I've
made videos on Japanese gardens I don't
really have the experience of Chinese
gardens that I do for the Japanese ones
I haven't traveled to China I haven't
been to as many real Chinese gardens as
I have for Japanese garden so really
can't speak with as much authority here
but in the end I do want to create a
garden setting for this pavilion because
you'll very commonly find these kinds of
pavilions in traditional Chinese gardens
and in fact I think there are lots of
similarities between Chinese and
Japanese gardens if you look overall
they are both meant to be a sort of
miniature replica of a natural landscape
using a lot of rock work and bushes and
trees and also very easy exactly winding
paths and water elements to try and
create a sort of smaller natural
landscape which i think is really cool
and what I like about Japanese gardens
in the first place and how I think in
plants ooh specifically a lot of the
foliage and work work and pathways that
work for Japanese gardens could just as
easily work for Chinese gardens as well
really a major difference that I tried
to incorporate a bit here as well is
that while Japanese gardens as even
though there are many different types
are really overall meant to be walked
through and they don't really feature as
much architecture whereas Chinese
gardens typically tend to feature many
more buildings and are much more seen
from inside a building setting rather
than strolled through as you do with
many Japanese strolling garden to tea
gardens or lake based gardens so that's
I guess have made a difference
but for both of these I think there's a
fair set of scenery out there in the
game to make these things not to mention
that the cherry blossom tree is
absolutely beautiful and I tried to use
this conservatively so there's only one
cherry blossom tree which is in that
very strategic position at this junction
of all of these paths at the end of the
bridge which I think works out quite
well but yeah there's a really beautiful
tree probably my favorite one in the
game obviously they're really beautiful
in real life but this transition in the
game is just so beautifully pink I
really can't put it in a different way
it's just really nice to look at and I
think it even goes very well with the
path textures of this kind of assorted
cobblestone path and the same goes for a
lot of the other foliage I'm not as big
a fan of the Japanese maple they've
definitely gone for more of an orange
color whereas I do like the dark red
purple is almost : that they often have
in real life but yeah I ended up putting
some Japanese maples in there as well
might not be the most Chinese thing but
at the same time it just works for the
overall look of the garden not to
mention that at the end of the day you
can't really make a completely authentic
Japanese of Chinese gardens these things
are very very much based on ceremonial
and cultural traditions which you can
never really recreate yourself
especially me just being a dumb
Westerner so it's really all just
inspired by it and trying to take the
aesthetic and mold it into a zoo here
although at the same time I'm really
trying to keep the garden esque elements
to just the path areas and keep the
actual habitats of the bears as natural
as possible speaking of which I actually
skipped through a whole section of me
working on the habitat itself just
because I didn't record it it was a lot
of me looking around the habitats trying
to do some stuff trying to figure out
how I wanted to build it it didn't work
as well for a time-lapse but yeah in the
meantime I did work on the habitat
itself as well now here kind of running
behind I started working on some roof
sets and this is really giving me
sometimes Isabella flashbacks because I
tried making pretty
much the exact same roof sent in fantasy
valley a combination of three main roof
pieces to make these Asian typical
curved roofs with a straight piece with
a slight curve to it and a larger steep
piece to try and fill in larger roof
structures and finally the most
difficult thing to get right the corner
piece which curves upward and which is
quite difficult to make it work but for
this one at least I learned from the
mistakes that I made on the pavilion so
I made it out of different pieces that I
tested beforehand and really wouldn't
disappear too quickly and the piece that
I ended up going with to make the roof
tiles out of is the letter e so that's
kind of a meme honestly but yeah it just
worked out that the eave was the best
shape to make these roof tiles out of so
I ended up going with the E and then for
the corners the these stone sections I'm
just taking some limestone pillars now
the thing about these types of Asian
roofs is that I can really only try to
imitate the look that these roofs have
from a distance because obviously I
don't have actual roof tiles but Chinese
and Japanese roof tiles are very similar
they're very different from most western
roof tiles in that they are you've got
round cap pieces and then round valley
pieces and they both intermingled it's
it's like a mix of the two of them so
often if you look at an Asian roof you
can find at the bottom of the roof round
pieces and then a half moon freshen
shape downwards and then a round piece
again etc so these roofs tend to have
very typical look even if you look at
them from a distance and that's
basically the look that I tried to
imitate by sinking these EES inward a
little bit and then raising the other
one up again kind of intermittently is
that a word I don't know anyway you get
the drift I'm trying to make these roofs
look vaguely Asian even though they are
made out of the letter e and also that
did include putting some full stops at
the end of these roofs I know I said I
wouldn't use
. anymore but for this one just to have
that detail when you look up close i
decided to put these at the end just to
at least imitate a little bit the
decorations that you have at the end of
these tiled roofs because they're very
very decorated i find in general even
that while a lot of european
architecture really focuses on the walls
themselves and kind of leave the roofs
with maybe just a few decorations some
railings and some dormers Asian and
Chinese architecture focuses much more
on the roof the roof is a much larger
parts of the general structure of the
building and is much more detailed
whereas the lower sections of the
building are much more simple at least
as far as the attending goes so here too
I'll be spending most of my time on this
building just trying to perfect the roof
and then the rest is basically just
filling to me whoa I just destroyed my
whole setup anyway the rest is just
basically filling in everything else I'm
trying to reset up my pop filter and
everything here in the meantime I'm
gonna try to actually pay attention to
the video shouldn't be too bad but yeah
that that is basically my general
approach to this building now something
that I didn't really talk about but
which i think is relevant to point out
as well
is that this building was mostly
inspired by a building in Japan actually
in Shinjuku Gyoen which is a park in
Shinjuku in Tokyo there is a Taiwanese
pavilion in the middle of the park which
is a really cool building to view the
garden from and it was actually gifted
by Japanese people in Taiwan I believe
but very much Taiwanese style more so
than a Japanese style and I liked the
idea of having a building to view the
gone and from it's much more of a a
Chinese sort of thing but I think it
works out really well for this habitat
as well this will be the main viewing
platform to see the habitats from it is
right next to the shelter
which I did shelter a bit more with some
extra work work so the animals don't
completely have to be in view but yeah
it's I think right in front of this is
where the animals will be spending most
of their time where the food will be
delivered and things like that
so I think this would be a good viewing
place to see the habitat from a good
place to see animals and a good framing
for the habitat as a home because the
the perspective that you have from here
of the bridge and of all of the foliage
around the place I think looks really
cool so that's why I ended up putting
this building here and I just like the
picture of looking at the garden in the
distance with the pillars and
decorations of the building that you're
standing in in the foreground I think it
provides this really cool foreground
background interaction that I really
like so that's something that I ended up
going further with this building and
yeah that's my general idea behind the
placements and design of this building I
was also inspired by in general
Taiwanese temples but I can't really pin
this down on anything specific I have to
say that really all I did was open up a
Google Images tab and a search Taiwanese
temple and keep a bunch of images as
reference for ideas to see you know what
the color scheme should be like how I
should do it things like that I often
get the question of what inspires me
where I get my ideas from and honestly a
lot of it is religious googling at
random and seeing what you like seeing
what you can draw ideas from and what
you can base general structures on
because obviously I'm not an expert in
Chinese architectures and having
references images that that's too many
plural words whether it really should
have been singular anyway having these
references images why do I keep doing
this having these reference images in
the background can really help to try
and get an idea of what you should do
definitely not going to be perfectly you
know authentic but at the end of the day
I'm just some dude in Belgium making
zoos in a video game so at some point
yeah I suppose you do have to zoom out
and kind of consider who you are and
where you are and that I really probably
shouldn't worry as much about these
things as I do sometimes
and as for the use of this building I
put some shops in it right now but this
is actually going to be your toilet
building eventually because I didn't
want to put shops inside this building
and make it too busy to look at the
animals so I think toilets is maybe a
bit of a lame use for such a very
large-scale and detailed building but I
think it works out better in the context
of this habitat and not to mention and I
don't think the animals would want cue
lines for people eating burgers in front
of their habitat not to mention this
smell so yeah that's something that I
had to keep in mind and also in the
grand scheme of this habitats this
building does fulfill the function of
hiding the backstage areas I won't be
really building the backstage areas too
much or showing it off on the time-lapse
but I did add a backstage area with
electricity and water management's and
the keeper Hut's and all that kind of
thing I hope you don't hear my roommates
in the background and also realistically
I think this would be the space where a
holding area for the Bears would be
where staff could bring the Bears to an
area with no views of the guests for
care outside of opening times which
realistically you need to have in a zoo
as well and even though it's not part of
the game it's something that I at least
want to feature to some extent to make
it all feel a bit more realistic and a
bit more like it could actually be real
you know now I want to finish this video
off with some random things that I found
out about the Formosan black bears
because I thought it was interesting
aspect apparently they don't hibernate
they just go to lower areas in Taiwan
the total population of these guys is
actually unknown although they are
endangered and they are kind of a mascot
of the country as well they're really
popular and there are a bunch of
different mascots of black bears for all
kinds of organizations as well which are
really cute I love how countries like
China Korea Japan seem to love their
animal mascots also I Khosla
overestimated or actually now I grossly
underestimated just how much the
difference between males and females
would be because the male black tie
black bears are really huge or at least
about human size and then the females
are really tiny it's really weird to see
that
anyway that's it for this video I'm just
going to leave you guys with some
cinematic shots of the Bears enjoying
their habitats and yeah I guess I'll see
you in the next planet view video when
the full game comes out
unfortunately this park will be lost so
this footage is all that is saved of
this habitats but really I want to
stress that in the end this has all been
more of a practice run for me and a way
to try and get inspired about habitats
and building zoos and I might bring back
some design ideas from these pure beta
builds into whatever I'll end up
designing to build in the full game but
yeah it's it's been fun I think to work
on these and to try and practice and get
to know the game and I will miss it in
the next couple of weeks so thank you
guys for watching thanks for tyr for
bringing out this beta and I hope to see
you in the next video in a few weeks of
the full game bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]